now Russia says attacks on its border
region of Belgard continued in the early
hours of Wednesday the defense Ministry
says numerous drones entered the
territory but most were shot down and
they caused minimal damage Russia says
it killed 70 Fighters that had crossed
the border calling them Ukrainian
nationalists Ukraine has denied any
involvement well two anti-kremlin groups
claimed responsibility for the Belgard
attacks but the U.S has distanced itself
from reports that it supplied the
liberty of Russia Legion and the Russian
volunteer Corps with equipment Moscow
released pictures showing abandoned
vehicles in the Belgard area including
U.S made Humvees let me say a few things
about it number one we've seen
some of the reports circulating on
social media and elsewhere making claims
that U.S supplied weapons were used in
these attacks I will say that we're
skeptical at this time of the veracity
of these reports as a more General
Principle as we've said and I believe I
said yesterday we do not encourage or
enable strikes inside of Russia and
we've made that clear
but as we've also said it is up to
Ukraine to decide how to conduct this
war
well let's bring in Anton chekovstov
he's the director of the center for
Democratic integrity and also the author
of Russia and the Western far right he
joins us now from Vienna Anton can you
tell us a little more about these groups
the liberty of Russia Legion and the
Russian volunteer Corps I know they're
now saying they control pockets of
territory just how large or powerful are
they
well first of all hello and uh thank you
for having me
um if we're talking about those two
units I would rather talk about only one
unit uh which is the Russian volunteer
Corps uh this is a fighting unit that
actually exists not only on paper
uh but also like in real life so this
Liberty of Russia Legion or I would
prefer to call it the freedom of Russia
Legion it's more of a sort of
information project that was designed in
order to facilitate the surrender of
Russian Kremlin controlled soldiers and
officers to the Ukrainian forces giving
them hope or an idea to join Ukraine in
fighting the Kremlin so it's it's more
it's more of a project that may in fact
uh it's it's at some point in the future
become real become a real fighting force
but at the moment it's just a project
yes sir I wanted to ask you about the
fighters themselves and when you caught
when you're talking about the Russian
volunteer Corps for instance are those
Fighters all Russian I spotted some
Ukrainian Insignia on their uniforms in
a video statement we saw earlier
yeah uh look uh they are of course they
are all Russian citizens uh they are not
necessarily ethnic Russians not only
ethnic Russians but they are all Russian
citizens so uh even if they carry some
Ukrainian Insignia uh it only means that
they are part of the Ukraine Armed
Forces
um International Legion uh they they do
have this uh unit which is quite large
unit it's only it not only uh has
Russian Nationals but also belarusians
as well uh so it's a they have Georgian
Legion as well this is this is just part
of the uh a larger uh Ukrainian
International Legion so this is why they
carry a Ukrainian Insignia but they are
all Russian citizens sure what are they
hoping to achieve I know they've said
previously this is a hearts and Minds
war that they believe they're fighting
uh indeed but uh you know we cannot
really talk about one unifying ideology
of the Russian volunteer Corps uh if we
are if we're talking about one single
idea that unites all of them is the idea
of the Russian National Liberation
struggle they believe that the Kremlin
and Putin and his colleague they have
colonized Russian people that they are
pursuing an anti-russian agenda you know
making Russia you know uh
uh you know like a failure uh they they
consider this war as a failure as a as a
conflict between two very close Nations
so they are uh they're fighting to
liberate Russia from what they see as
the colonizing Kremlin force uh some of
them also believe that they want to have
a Russian national state a Russian
nation-state which means that they may
even opt for a smaller Russia you know
uh to to offer an opportunity to
non-ethnic Russian republics or
territories uh to seed and form their
own States because they really want to
have actually something like Ukraine or
Belarus or in here many other European
States Anton I'm I'm wondering where in
this fight where are they getting their
weapons what do you make of these
allegations they're using these U.S
supplied arms
that I really don't know uh what what
weapons they are using what weapons they
have and where they get from
I uh I can only presume that since they
are parts of the uh Ukrainian Armed
Forces uh since they're part of the
international Legion uh you know this
may give us a hint uh to where they
actually taking weapons from sure Anton
chakotstov he's the director of the
center for Democratic Integrity speaking
to us from Vienna really great to get
your thoughts on Al Jazeera thank you
for joining us Anton